[Music]
street
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you thought this [ __ ] started at three
trick directions
that's two that's two swings
in the bank baby those are free you
gotta take them out
tommy just has to start paying for that
that's fair
welcome back to the break room
baby it's day four and we're feeling
punchy okay this is our daily show that
keeps you updated on just what's going
on in nerve news from our very own break
room here at the new rock stars hq in in
beautiful downtown burbank california um
probably shouldn't give that much effort
maybe
maybe perhaps truly truly our break room
and this is our live show here at new
rock stars week one uh we're so happy to
have you with us today we're gonna be
talking about a lot of stuff i mean this
is a crazy week
in nerd culture is it moon night finale
doctor strange multiverse madness we got
an obi-wan trailer yesterday we got a
game of thrones prequel trailer today
who knows what tomorrow will bring okay
but some of the things we're gonna be
talking about today we got more moon
night stuff obviously we're all still
decompressing uh processing that finale
we've got a lot of topics to talk about
karen gillian
maybe we're tiring his nebula
quick beatty tease
christian bale maybe the best villain
ever in the mcu what uh black adam may
be getting delayed
and one of us may be getting hacked
all of that and so much more uh we're
mugging and chugging here
do rock
i'm here with uh three of my best
friends uh we got uh mr burbank himself
tommy beckham what's
stop
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then um well he's coming from west
hollywood
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when i'm not eating at lowry's
steakhouse
and wearing my epic hero merch uh i i
definitely shop at clickbaity tees you
know what i mean i get all my babies i
get all my babies
we are feeling good today
speaking of feeling good yeah we
appreciate you being here with us
blowing up the chat we're gonna have
some polls we're gonna be asking you
some questions we love all the feedback
obviously if you feel like throwing in a
super chat love to you much appreciation
thank you for that we'll try to shout
those out during the show and we have
another way you can participate in this
show if you want to throw a couple
doubloons a couple pesos couple uh
marks marks yeah whatever whatever your
trunks franxx lira whatever your
original currency might be into the
swear jar now the break room swear jar
as it stands right now is a like a
reverse swear jar normally your mom
makes you put a buck in the swear jar
when you cuss instead when we hit a
certain dollar amount on our swear jar
that makes us cuss yeah we've got some
good ones cooked up for you
tommy's been in the lab okay he's he's
been in the cursed lab and he's got he's
got some brand new ones he's ready to
unveil we ain't talking spells
okay so you can do um is it exclamation
mark tips yeah that's right just
and that will let you know how you can
go about doing that exclamation mark tip
um did you just say exclamation mark
just the tip yes that's it
in this yeah it'll um directed to my
personal only fans page all tip no shaft
what huh excuse me
call tim no
no i don't know what you're talking
about let's move on intro
we already did that sorry oh my gosh
well as zach is the one uh introducing
us and hosting us i'm the one that gets
to read the headlines oh baby
and we've got some answers we got
answers to the mandalorian showing up so
heavily in the book of boba fett which i
think is a question we all kind of had
yes watching the book of boba fett like
why is the mandalorian why is this just
chandelorian season three all of a
sudden yeah it's so much i mean not
saying i didn't like it i really loved
the mandalorian in the book of overfit
so dave filoni and john favreau felt it
would be difficult to go the entire
season without c and mando seeing as
mando and boba are friends that's true
and everyone and they also are like the
top built not top build but like
mandalorian is like the biggest thing in
that crowd
it's the crown jewel it's the tip not
the shaft
well you know some people are more shaft
than me
yeah
okay
we're talking about golf
clubs i was talking about golf club nice
a nice wedge yeah
my grandma's watching the show come on
i'm sorry me mom i'm sorry for the
farming in kentucky yeah let's begin
keeping away the actresses of my family
man all right well let's be very
specific three one five birds
okay also unfortunately like zach said
in the beginning black adam producers
say the delay is happening due to the
vfx which i think happened also with
aquaman too yeah uh it happened with the
flash too i think uh they said what's
going on with them
well this this feels like they're
throwing the vfx guys under the block
wasn't that also the justification given
for uh the marvels and ant-man flipping
oh yeah yeah the marvel's vfx was taking
a lot longer yeah because the ant-man's
vfx you only have to do a little bit of
they're so small and someone's easier
and so you have to make the giant hello
kitty pez dispenser hitting a bunch of
cars
no you just take it you make the regular
size hello kitty and you stretch it out
ant-man 3 is going to be all practical
it's all practical
that would be so funny it's shrink
yes
we'll reenact that later but now it has
been pushed october 21st instead of the
july premiere was supposed to be okay
still this year yeah
this year we're gonna get it just in
time for my birthday
it is still in time for his birthday
okay i guess uh taika watissi said thor
love and thunder has the best villain
the marvels uh that marvel cinematic
universe has ever seen in christian bale
what if it's just him he means just him
off yeah
nobody destroyed more craft services
i do love stories like these when
they're all i mean this is a great press
pr story where it's like oh he's the
best villain what are they gonna say
he's the third best villain we've ever
had
in the middle of the past he phoned it
in pretty hard this time uh we we were
hoping for something pretty great out of
these christian battles won an academy
award i will say we all love the the
meme or the footage of benedict
cumberbatch's smaug from uh the hobbit
right doing the mocap
and how hard he committed and you know
in the footage of christian bale when
mocap for gore comes out you it will be
the most intense smoke you've ever seen
he's a guy he's a method actor he loses
weight he gains weight i heard he went
to heaven and killed god for this movie
he got the biggest beard he could find
got very thin at first got big again
climbed a mountain and touched the sky
and said i'm gonna kill everyone i'm
gonna kill god
the psycho was like where are you for
this movie now
oh sony and marvel studios have made it
so so clear
that they're gonna make
another spider-man movie uh starring tom
holland zendaya with john watts
directing yes um it hasn't been
announced yet it clearly has not been
announced yet though marvel and sony are
hopeful to have them there's no work uh
just yet on what they might be doing
yeah we we we our crack team over here
the four of us yes uh scouring the
internet today trying to find like proof
everyone's talking about this fourth
movie and like sony's very much like oh
yeah we expect
john watson horse and dyer to come back
in a very mafioso style way like you
better show up for but not not the guy
who plays ned we are actually helping
people jacob
it's one of the most profitable or
largest grossing movies of all time of
course they want to make and especially
with john watts dropping out of
directing things yes before i'm sure
sony's like all right let's claim this
yeah also he's probably just taking that
much-needed break like how many
how long was it since that first
spider-man came out and there's been six
years he did the three movies six years
three movies
these are huge movies there's a ton of
work he probably just wants to take a
break do a rom-com you know do an indie
horror flick come back call us we'll
make a movie with you john
come out here make a movie in our studio
the break room the movie oh oh
breaking all the rooms all tip no
all tip no i mean
i'm sold i'm sold
we are up to four dollars and twenty
cents
okay i assume that was from one donor
yeah tip tip if you got them later thank
you uh as stony magoo
we'll be packing up those swear bongs
and blazing them in no time oh god
uh speaking of
bongs karen gillan
wrapped as nebula and guardians of the
galaxy three um in a very
heart-wrenching post which i don't know
if we do have there it is
she says i don't know if nebula will
return beyond this it's possible that
this is her final chapter
is this her final chapter because james
gunn mentioned like they're not doing
any more guardians well they said
he's kind of said like this iteration of
the guardians will be done yes so in
theory some of them could come back some
of them could go away but like and it
sounds like he's kind of done telling
this story yeah he doesn't want to do
the guardian stuff anymore but he still
loves doing the superhero thing that he
loves at this point it will have been
three full movies a holiday special they
they also appeared
in the community
they will be in thor 11th thunder right
that's a lot for this cast to that
director right maybe they do feel like
this could be a nice end to the story i
would say given her
off-screen kind of real-life personality
and persona i would be shocked if karen
gillan would turn down the opportunity
to play nebula she seems to really enjoy
this type of you know fantasy science
superhero comic book type material so
and i would imagine with a character
that interesting if there's a chance to
bring her back in like you know captain
marvel 100 without marvel's or something
like that or anything in space
she's probably gonna say yes you know
and and and they'll be lucky to have her
she's great i think that's what the
meaning of her post was is like it might
be the end for me just because it's like
when the other movies come out we will
probably see her again i hope that's the
first person they snatch she's one of my
favorite characters nebula
is an icon
um okay so moon knight director and i'm
so sorry might butcher this name
muhammad dayab muhammad
ali
and i'm sorry for butchering uh revealed
two major cameos were cut from the show
during scripting uh people clearly
heavily expected the hulk sharon carter
blade werewolf blind knight
i want to know what the chat thinks but
i want to do something fun also
okay i want to assign you guys one of
these okay and i want to hear your take
on
what this was the person how they would
show up in moonlight
zach
i'm gonna give you sharon carter sharon
carter well we know she's a world
traveler
right she's got she's connected to
criminal networks
all over the world there's a decent
chance right we we only got hints of
mark as moon knight him out there
killing bad guys right we saw a lot of
his victims as kind of zombified uh
afterlife creatures right but we can
assume through her underworld
connections maybe moon knight and sharon
carter crossed paths maybe moon knight
killed some of sharon carter's
henchman or sharon and jake
oh maybe sharon
maybe maybe he had some interaction
something like that so maybe there could
have been a flashback you know to that
oh that that night in sydney or that
that mission in bangkok or whatever
right and we see uh an overlap you know
uh
mark reckenshaw wait a second
team michael bechtel wants to talk to
you about
[Laughter]
a studio executive in hollywood he'll be
here don't worry he'll be here next week
that's that's a taste of things to come
something tells me team michael will be
here next week well you did mention the
layla with some andropor type stuff yeah
i think that that's where like sharon
definitely could have liked it so it
might have been right that's better you
just made my idea better i'm gonna give
you yeah i'm gonna give you the hulk the
hulk okay well i'm going to give you my
pitch in honor of the king of mexicans
who gave us twenty dollars and asked us
to say his name i thought you were
pointing to dasher
thank you for your 20 tip uh our
contribution thank you for saying you
love us we love you too of course and uh
i appreciate you being held grateful i'm
hella grateful for you king of mexicans
you know what else i'm hella grateful
for the fact that this hulk pitch is
still out there in the ether somewhere
because
i think
the uh layla looking for answers
searching for
uh
some some egyptians some science
irregularities going on in egypt seeks
out some of the great science minds in
our world and we have a de-powered
uh bruce banner
sitting in a council of of minds of
people that have been like looking at
different energy things that have been
coming out of the the pyramids and
showing up in egypt and all across the
world with uh you know with uh harrow
rapturing people with his cane and uh
and you just kind of get a bruce banner
like
i don't know i've seen a lot of weird
stuff in my life
and then cut to the last episode
where bruce is aware that there's stuff
going on in egypt he senses all of these
he's you know with with the technology
that the avengers have he senses the
irregularities and when uh the big
fight's happening all of a sudden you
just see one of those uh
tourist buses from the tv show because
they love ruining a bus flip up in the
air and then he just looks around and he
sees jake lockley has
murdered uh
murdered like 35 people and he just goes
hulk leave now
and then he turns around and leaves
because because they had like an 80 cgi
budget yeah yeah oh so you can just show
up and go poke not participating
and i'm gonna last but not least i'm
gonna give you blade blade oh okay okay
blade i i think i would have loved uh
uh the so the situation happens at the
museum with the jackal ride the bathroom
getting destroyed oh you know uh
um
steven goes to the security guard this
is like
rj or v dj or something he had a like
initial name jd thank you i was so close
oh stop close thank you director john
thank you john thank you so much john
all that happens it would be the footage
haha it's nothing you're crazy mate
right stephen goes in the office to uh
uh talk to the boss who lets uh gives
him like that a very nice boss who gave
him like health care information and was
like get help buddy uh but do we cut
back to the station and dj's still
working there or whatever and or jd i
forget would already forget what john
said
jd
and then we hear a voice we hear i need
to take a look at that footage
because blade's worried that it's a
vampire wandering around and then shout
out to our uh one of our favorite hosts
here that we haven't seen in a while but
we hope to see you soon marina masteros
he looks at the footage and goes some
[ __ ] always trying to ice skate
uphill
[Music]
the dead jar wasn't there yet
so what is that a reverend that's from
played trinity that's wesley snipe says
oh my god and i think in werewolf by
night there's just going to be an epic
fight scene with the werewolf changing
by the moon yeah yeah truly like i don't
know what's happening and mark's like i
gotta kill you that would have been
perfect at like when they're at midnight
man's compound or whatever oh
and like you know steven lines up to
fight somebody and the guy's standing
there and the clouds move away and you
see
well and they could even yeah they could
retcon it because midnight man is like i
collect all kinds of crazy artifacts
maybe he has some kind of magical
werewolf amulet or something like that
right
i think i want to hear if everybody else
agrees with us but i also want to hear
if there's a different cameo you guys
might think it doesn't have to be
werewolf by night it doesn't have to be
blade doesn't have to be whole doesn't
have to be sharon carter it could be
anyone maybe this is the chance for a
little mini pole of those four yeah who
do you guys think was most likely to
appear truly i like this blade one the
most
but i also just love blade
uh
last another one from muhammad uh the
director er yeah for moon knight also
mentioned that he'd love to take moon
knight next to the big screen he said we
could journey into the different lives
of different characters in the mcu but
also seeing more jake and layla which i
think we all would like and i also think
that would make a great movie yes yeah
uh there's so much oh there's so much
moon night stuff coming up oscar isaac
said he'd be happy to come back for
season two right better
feels like he better bowl take care i
love being stephen i just i love money
it's just like physically it's so much
fun to be here yeah and you know what he
didn't physically get to be as much moon
knight you know i was kind of an origin
story and he spent a lot of time i bet
he'd love to be in that suit a little
bit more punching and kicking i mean i'm
still blown away in the scenes where he
switches from like mark to stephen
there's no cut yeah it's him like doing
it it's great for an actor i'd be like
this is a great deal just like testing
your skills and they love doing that
also this is definitely different from
ex machina for him uh that's always the
first thing i think of him in oh um i
think of inside lou and davis
yeah dear mr kennedy
oh the inside louis louis davis fans
going wow
come on that has kylo ren
justin timberlake and moon knight all in
one song and lastly moon night season
two is still up in the air i know that
i've tweeted about it everyone's talking
about it uh they never discussed making
a season two and when asked they said
that they're kept in the dark just like
us
[Music]
only feige knows the truth
only for only
speaking of moonlight speaking of moon
night uh we we should do our like finale
round table i think okay for moon night
uh and that's gonna be part of our break
room breakdown today uh we have a clip
from the breakdown that got posted to
the channel today that eric worked very
hard on he did such a good job we gave
him a little treat yeah you're being
such a good little boy
thank god again
but there was a very interesting part of
the breakdown i thought we could talk
about here today on the show uh jon roll
that clip for us please
stephen wakes up in harrow's office
where they now see the blood pooling
from his sandals the implication might
be that harrow's feet in the series were
always bleeding but mark steven all of
us did not see it until now but this
office i believe is not real not like
the rest of the hospital that we saw on
episode 5 the hospital was their
perspective of the duot underworld ship
rather this room is their organizing
principle representing their
subconscious self-doubt so last episode
they would suddenly teleport back to
this room when one of them suffered a
mental break so this ned flanders is not
hero it's the embodiment of doubt that
heroes antagonism represents for them
and now that they see harrow as a
bleeding mortal he truly is they are no
longer trapped under their doubts
control they control it here's my hand i
can see the chat
yes yes dark c t r d asking are we
reading chat we are reading chat mega
math game we got a lot of work to do
that's a funny way you know that's a
real pick me move okay yeah yeah and i
picked you you got [ __ ] we felt right
for him michael adams gore was right we
didn't even know the movie hasn't come
out yet we don't know it's right or
wrong
that's that's what i wanted to talk
about with you guys like what is
real on this show
what what was actually i believe i like
the way you explained this to me because
i got to be honest maybe i'm dense maybe
it's my public school education even
after watching eric's video i'm not sure
that i fully could wrap my head around
it but then you did explain it pretty
well yeah so kind of think of if you
remember if you remember the movie
inception that's another way to think of
it dreams within dreams so
when they're in the hospital the psych
ward in the last two episodes right that
is the manifestation and we say they
that's steven
yeah when they're in the bingo area and
they're going to the rooms of the
sarcophaguses right that's all real in
the sense that it's part of the
afterlife which is real on this show
right
it's a place you can physically go
anything in harrow's office where it's
just harrow talking to jake or or or
stephen or mark that's all within the
mind of mark slash stephen within the
afterlife within the afternoon it is as
if you are having a daydream while being
in heaven
it's a construct of like harrow and this
is what eric is saying like harrow is
their own self-doubt like that they are
they are crazy and none of this is real
and like they can't be trusted and bubba
which is kind of a beautiful concept if
like the thing that is the dream within
a dream
is simulating not being in a dream at
all wow right right and so what eric is
saying is like everything we saw on the
show was real except for anything that
takes place in that office within the
psych ward yeah but i still think uh and
he was talking about this on his
breakdown for episode five that like
some of those memories aren't real like
when mark is standing outside of the
house in chicago and like there's no
other there's one taxi that passes by
but no people on the street the street's
walled off it almost looks like a set i
mean it was obviously filmed on a set
but it looks so much like yes yeah like
i think and like the whole cave scenario
could be fake like that could be
something that was planted in mark's
mind to make him weary uh we talked
about some of these on rogue theory
which you'll see tomorrow but uh yeah
some some crazy stuff i think there's
more not real stuff on this show i agree
[Laughter]
wow i'm so confused
it is so hard to wrap my head around so
you three go on well and then i was just
gonna say one thing that confused me
upon initial watching but again brandon
explain it to me a little better but
then when we see
actual arthur harrow in an asylum at the
end of episode six you know when he gets
in the they they break him out and he
goes in the limousine or whatever that's
real real that's not the afterlife
asylum that's an actual london asylum
right now how we got to london we're not
sure
uh but i am seeing the sand in the cup
i don't know if we're we as the audience
are seeing what harrow is seeing and his
mind is starting to crack because he's
had a god put inside of his body right
or is that me
messing with him or he's on it messing
with him oh you know yeah yeah yeah
we're going to attempt to remind him
because he's probably
like the way we saw
mark and steven getting pretend drugged
in their subconscious or in their you
know whatever in their in their uh their
doubtful mind or whatever
right we can assume that arthur harrow
is getting real life sedated as a
violent man who just attempted to kill
the majority of the people in cairo
and if you believe that no one could see
the giant ahmed right right you just
assume arthur herrera is the one taking
that song right right jesus christ
he's not involved in this bingo demaio
so are you saying
that
so the the place that arthur harrow is
in the hospital is it
is in stephen and mark's mind no no no
with the mustache wait when did you have
a mustache
did you watch the show when he's the
doctor i'm thinking of the end when he
doesn't in the end that's all real we
are thinking beyond maybe the sand
coffee cup yeah yeah
didn't wasn't there
i guess mark and steven always appeared
in that room i thought they were taken
from that first room to that room where
we saw them playing bingo so is that
part also a part of arthur harrell's
mind we we see the we he always cuts to
the offense it cuts through the
obviously okay i thought he got like and
it's usually when he's having like uh
some sort of chaos going on within the
hospital it'll like cut to the office
and it's like hey you were just
imagining but you're not like someone
commented jess is all of us right now
so jess do not you're not alone yes
it's meant to be confusing it's meant to
be an unreliable narrator right at the
end of the show pen and paper omit's not
or ahmed is not using here as an avatar
ahmed is inside trapped inside of him
like he's like he's a clay statue
doesn't care for that that gets us to
another question you want to ask right
we see jake with his silencer pistol pop
off a couple rounds in the general
direction of arthur harrow we can assume
he's a good shot do we think that means
harrow and by
by proxy ahmet are both kaput
finito dead forever
yes i was when i read this too because i
was like if you kill harold can ahmed
get out now
if if ami is still trapped inside of her
hair right now yes
and we we've been told by the rules of
the show that like you can harm a god if
they're inside the body of a human wait
literally yeah literally got that long
you can literally do that we literally
got you're made flash if you shoot him
dead cause remember he farts poncho
wanted to kill harold right away using
mark stephen and they were like no we're
not going to do it we're not going to
kill him
i won't kill him i won't do it
i've got a better bet
don't do it all of all of our european
fans let's get out it's way too late for
any uk viewers i think we're viewers
that do like me they they tweet me and
tell me my accent is atrocious
and those are the ones that like you
yeah who's that like man we don't care
what you think about
the only
british things i have are like oliver
twist so i don't really have a lot to
worry about
so if if harold is dead if jake's a
great shot like old zacky boy said do
you think we'll ever see him again yes
well no here's what i'll say
the thing that the nice benefit of the
marvel disney plush shows being pg-13
maybe even a little softer right
is they have to show a lot of these
deaths off-screen yeah right you don't
see a bullet going through the forehead
of our area or something like that yeah
so it leaves just a little bit of
ambiguity there because what if ethan
hawk comes to feige's office and is like
listen
i was in boyhood yeah i did i did school
time i was in love okay i was in the
sunset sunrise truly the the lgbt people
okay
but they're all
the role i was meant to play was arthur
you know they could bring him back they
could justify it someone in the chat
said arthur harrow is daddy and then
followed up with steve and his daddy and
both of those are incorrect
i got bad news for you tommy is daddy
because it's time for mandatory for fun
mandatory fun baby
i talked over the graphic
hit it again
that's a good graphic yes this is my
time where i make my three best friends
join me in a little non-optional joy
we're having fun now every day we do
mandatory fun it's not voluntary fun
otherwise it would just be me up here
and these three would be going to get a
doughnut in the water it's mandatory fun
all right today we're looking finally
back at moon night as we have all
episode specifically our predictions now
before we get into what we predicted on
this very show
tuesday i want you guys to look back at
all of the predictions that you made
about moon night over the last six weeks
and maybe just give me your maybe your
biggest whiff or your greatest sniff oh
i'm gonna fart right now my biggest
whiff which i wanted to be a sniff yeah
you know
some of you out there know we've we've
been working on this show very hard you
might think they slapped this piece of
crap together in two seconds but no this
took a lot of hard work a lot of
practice we did some practicing
throughout the whole run of moon night
we were making all these predictions one
i stuck by that i really thought we were
going to get yeah i thought we were
going to get some butt cheek oh yeah
you know what i mean he got a cheek
disney plus they've implemented uh
parental guidance
they got clothes on there now yeah they
got they got kingpin smashing a head and
a door we can see that but we can't see
some good old american butt we got
jessica jones and luke cage going hard
in the board
do you get a little you get a little
butt cheek you get a little luke cage
butt chicken
you get a ham hock
you get it i thought
i thought we were for sure going to see
oscar isaac's butt on this show i
thought in egypt when you walked through
the window i was like this is the moment
it's happening we can get oscar isaac
button a lot of other things well that's
what i mean but it's not the same if it
doesn't have a disney art i
along that same line of total
uh stupid minutiae that i was hoping for
you know the majority of the series set
in the middle east i guess a lot in
london and then the middle east um and
though we got layla eating some like
turkish delight multiple times
i was hoping for hummus oh yeah okay i
was grappling for bob
chickpeas okay i was uh i was uh
tickling for tabbouleh okay i wanted
some great you brought one for grape
leaves that's right
i was i was mooching for meza okay i
just stopped wanted
you were pandering for peta
i was i was convention for kebab okay i
just wanted some middle eastern food
showcased on this scene on this show we
did get a great scene in the finale
there's a whole family that's over
dinner it gets blown away yeah and i
mean i needed some slo-mo passes on that
food okay i wanted to see the little
pools of olive oil with a little pepper
just like close-ups of oh my god yes i
think uh my biggest whiff was that the
security guard jd had a bigger
involvement like i was like i was on
every single i was on big question i was
on rogue theory i was on this show and
i'm like no you guys don't understand
it's all about jd it's always been jd
this is jd's show mark spector's just
living in it and turns out that guy just
uh made about two thousand dollars to be
a guest a coach he didn't even make it
did he make it as one of the cameos in
the asylum later when the boss laid it
down he didn't see him
all right jessica anything for you no
none of mine were back all right get out
all right then we're going to get into
our official break room predictions in a
little segment we like to call age-like
wine aged like milk
which ones were delicious which ones
curdled
could not be turned into butter or
cottage cheese so we actually let's
start with uh with the ones that we got
right because some of us got some really
good predictions right i only got one
prediction close to right so i'll go
first i said that stephen would be back
in the finale in relatively quick
fashion and i would say it's fair to say
he was back and featured pretty
prominently
yeah yeah yeah all right what about you
i literally got none of my predictions
correct yeah i predicted this show would
tie in to secret invasion no hint of
that no skulls show up you don't know
that yet that's true fair gt iron was a
scroll yeah okay
we all know he took the corner
immediately
i predicted steven would not show up he
was there uh very much so i predicted
now i got kind of close i predicted
layla would resurrect
uh mark
through konshu
she did it through tower rat as jessica
rightly predicted um and then what was
the fourth thing we had to predict we
had to predict
it was like the wasn't there like the
wild card the twist
oh and i think my twist was that oh that
um mark was bushman now that maybe maybe
jake was booked yeah yeah yeah maybe
jake was bushing so we don't know that
one yet okay when i got right sort of my
choice was that like jake was the alpha
i think that's fantastic alpha
personalities
i think he's the alpha
and tommy supports this i don't like i
don't know who's with him and he's like
i don't i want to jake the whole time i
don't care about your other two but i
was thinking that like jake was the
initial personality too maybe and that
mark and steven were both creations and
maybe the whole backstory about the
little brother is the character oh fake
jake was actually the personality of
like the little brother and there was no
real little brother yes and kant you
wanted mark to think that the
personality of jake was gone so he
manifested it as like a little brother
and made up the scenario where he drowns
in the cave all right okay so now it's
time for jessica to brag because jessica
really really killed her predictions so
in the final age like wine jessica go
off and tell us how wonderful she's a
delicious chablis that's right she's a a
tangy merlot yeah she's a mosquito i'm
gonna take uh this this one to take this
freaking roller coaster and i'm gonna
put it back on the tracks uh i think or
what i said was that layla comes back as
terroret college
i got right um i also said the biggest
twist was konshu is jake
and i said basically kanchu is with jake
so uh who also got that right i don't
want to hear brandon's uh it's the he's
the alpha i said it correct i was like
conscious jake that's the twist and also
not to be that person but mine is
actually a twist mine was that mine was
the end credits mine was the
post-credits scene twist yours was not
you're being my person you're being that
person you're gonna have some bruises on
your back from all that patent little
lady
all right now
now we got to get to some of the more
shameful portions of our prediction
in the age like milk i for one predicted
an eternals crossover uh that had no
chance of happening zach anything i mean
i i pretty much labeled all my milk uh
it is special it is curdled it is rancid
well as they say in real housewives of
the potomac why cry over spilt milk when
you can laugh over champagne dude
uh brandon and he spilled milk for us uh
i spilled some i said the crossover
would be like black panther oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was in the alley i also won
i was hard on uh harrow being anubis i
thought for sure
yeah that um we had a a super chat from
our friend uh vera morris uh i really
wish someone broke all the guys i was
going hard
unlike me i feel like a ten-year-old in
any kind of shopping aisle where i want
to knock over all the ketchup
and i was like girl you are putting your
hand gently on each of them you can just
knock them all back knock it down knock
it down knock it down also does i guess
if the building collapsed on it do they
still break let's hope so that's right
we're open for a big release yeah and
then also that that happened in the show
i want to call it a couple of our super
chatter moistus martin
9.99 absolutely love y'all can i get a
hell yeah
alison becker you guys could do this a
little earlier please 1am in norway we
can't even get this [ __ ] on the road at
three
what are you thinking allison we can't
even do this at the time we say we're
gonna all right now
we have to bring this home because john
is crying in the control booth director
john there's a winner there's a loser to
this okay okay the winner who had the
most correct predictions and i think
just overall nailed the show was jessica
yeah good job there's also a loser now
zach you claim you got none right but
really you had elements of multiple
predictions correct whereas one person
had absolutely nothing correct and that
was me
uh i had nothing right so we decided off
camera that the punishment for this is
that i will now become jessica's avatar
and jessica can command me to do
something and she says she has a really
devious thing and i'm very nervous about
what it is so to end mandatory fun i
hope in a fun way jessica's going to
tell me what i have to do now i'm going
to do something weird
i'm going to make it weird in here but
also hot i want you to go to twitter oh
god i want i want tommy to go to twitter
everybody go follow me i gotta get my
phone i think tommy's twitter is the
christmas boy it's not tommy coming back
hold on your name is just the christmas
boy if you're not already following
tommy back to what are you doing
this is not all just a long con to get
more followers
but right now this this will show you
that the show's live go to go to twitter
i'm on twitter tell me back i want you
in your best tommy way because i know i
can say this but i want you to say it
and i want to approve of it when you say
okay um i want you to ask for feet pics
oh no oh and the way i want to ask for a
feed picks is i want you to end it with
yum yum okay
oh okay
uh and if you're out there in the chat
and you have a pet maybe you take a
picture of your pet's feet send them the
phone send a picture of yourself
you want to send your feet you can but
don't feel obligated too yes send your
pet's feet send your neighbor's feet
well tommy type set up i do want to go
through the poll we ran earlier about uh
what cameo would you have liked to have
seen
in moon night uh weirdly 100 percent
feet
wait
oh you're joking
blade was the top uh vote getter 39
wanted to see blade cameo there hell
yeah brandon did a good pitch there kang
got 27 percent i was on the kangaroo
punisher at 18 percent
there is a strong and passionate
punisher fan base out there and it
really wants him to show up i used to do
the marvel role-playing game and we
always i would be uh punisher and my
friend would be moon knight and we would
always form an alliance and one time we
formed one with wolverine called three
dog night is this interesting time to
finish that tweet i to we did all right
this is what i wrote i said calling all
foot friends
please send me pics of your tantalizing
tootsies yum yum yes yes
hashtag and our breakfast
uh and i just want to mention to my
family and my girlfriend
everyone else
watching this now this is because i have
to no no wait if you take a picture of
yourself like a selfie also an attention
this is why you're never becoming an
avatar for anyone oh god i need to be
released
[Laughter]
oh no i want everyone to know it's real
we did have another super chat uh i'm
gonna butcher this name my apologies
jorge quiro squiros
heroes kiros maybe uh said thanks for
all your hard work you're the best hi
from costa rica hello
it's sent out and i'll let you know how
the responses are coming he also said uh
by the way i think we got our first view
of jake when steve blacked out in the
alps and recovered the scarab from the
herald clan which would make a lot of
questions
yeah and we never got confirmation if
that was that that was kind of before
mark and steven were really talking to
each other
it would make a lot of sense yeah yeah
so i like good good job jorge good job
good job
you have a lovely country i've been to
costa rica once had a great time
i've never been but i've been told by
the fbi i can travel out of the country
soon
so look for me in costa rica i like you
need to pre-apologize to your family for
that tweet but you're fine making jokes
like that
uh okay oh we got a couple quick things
and then we're going to talk about house
of the dragon uh that trailer we saw
that we love and we're very excited for
game of thrones again but real quick um
i'm modeling some uh epic hero shot
merch brandon also i got a hoodie uh i
had a mandalorian hat yes i shared on
earlier but i spilled a uh chicken
quesadilla from taco bell fair
they they are great shirts they're not
necessarily a quesadilla proof brand
there's a new
this just dropped today a multiverse of
madness latest obsession shirt currently
available for sale there it is in the
epic hero shop
new rockstars merch it's called i think
it's called shattered madness it's a
very cool design with kind of like a
doctor strange it's kind of like a big
shatter in the middle that almost looks
like like his heart is kind of exploded
and then in the middle of that there's
wanda anyways it's a great shirt
grab that uh oh we're already getting
some rough responses on twitter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
okay as we quickly as we quickly panning
uh too so today
no quite all right we've gotten teasers
before but we got our first
can i see your full trailer for house of
the dragon the upcoming hbo uh game of
thrones prequel series starring uh matt
smith patty considine uh rhys
rhys hyphens uh a lot of other english
actors they got everybody that wasn't in
the original game of thrones hornsby
huckle style yeah that's right crimson
cronkite that's
but uh i believe john are we gonna watch
the trailer
okay that's a risk we're willing to take
for you the fans even though we might
get copyright copyright stricken yeah uh
we're gonna roll that beautiful trailer
yeah
what is this
brief
mortal life
if not the pursuit of legacy
i reckon stark i call his volarian i
roman baratheon
promised to be faithful to king viserys
and to his named princess rhaenyra
manira targaryen
men would soon put the realm to the
torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
[Music]
we play an ugly game
[Music]
you have the determination to win it
[Applause]
[Music]
history does not remember blood
it remembers names
[Music]
come back you know what it's like you
have a bad breakup with a girlfriend or
boyfriend or whoever and you're like i
can't believe how bad things ended you
don't see them for a couple years and
then all of a sudden they post like a
picture on instagram of them like at a
fair with their hair blowing in the wind
eating like a popcorn and you're like
god i miss her and that's what that
trailer was for me i was like i've never
watched game of thrones again well i i
gotta say i love that trailer now i was
not as pissed i was a huge game of
thrones fan i was not as pissed about
the ending as a lot of folks oh wow i
enjoyed i enjoyed the overall experience
yes i'm ready for more content i will
say this
this series we were talking about this
in the office earlier after watching the
trailer for the first time it could be
the perfect solution to whatever your
problems were with game of thrones right
this is set several hundred years before
the events of the eight seasons of game
of thrones right so
none of these characters are still alive
that's when game of thrones happens
right uh and so they could die they
could live this is based on a book the
book um uh
what was it the book fire and blood fire
and blood is the book so this has been
published there is they are going to
follow kind of the george rr uh
storyline but like they can kind of
reset none of that bad taste
in your mouth that you had in game of
thrones i just realized who could still
be alive is the red woman because she's
kind of nice
right his head she couldn't be there
there's no ring hook there's a red woman
there well and yeah we could see some
characters or even like what we are
definitely going to see is a lot of
people's great great great grandfathers
and grandmothers right because we we
know there's starks we know there's
baratheons and we know there's a whole
lot of targaryens right right the white
wig budget on this show
okay was high
and yeah and like the lannisters exist
right now they're not as big yet but
they're they're like coming in to what
they're going to become because the
targaryens have been in charge for like
a hundred years at this point yes which
we're not used to on game of thrones
that we know where it was constant
switching yeah we're running around
targeting
one family in charge for a long time
because they got the dragos and it's so
nice of final i i'm seconding what you
said it's so nice to see this
way before game of thrones because it's
like oh i feel so bad i feel so bad and
it's like well now you get to see up
close and personal what they did well
and this is what i've always wanted from
like star wars right uh it's to get
really far away from what we do either
further in the future or
go way back in the past like
that like the game nights of the old
republic was so fun because it didn't
involve anyone it was all new characters
all new people so while these these
characters have been established through
histories in the books and the book
itself it is nice to be like oh these
are a whole new set of characters
writing must have been the hardest thing
in the world with this because they had
to go back and remember like well we
can't because this family does this
they have to get like game of thrones
like fans to write like research and you
know like it's gonna be cool because we
know this is building up too also one
thing when you watch the trailer closely
the cool thing about the trailer is
it's covering a lot of time yeah like
there are actors
with like completely different haircuts
and different shots and like there are
different actors playing the same
character like 10 years later and so
like we know we kind of all the game of
thrones seasons were kind of in real
time they were like micro kind of time
jumping they jumped a little bit yeah
but like this looks like maybe this very
first season is going to cover a big
span of time right from when some
characters are children jumping to them
being adulthood so that's cool it's a
different storytelling style than we got
in game of thrones and this is all
building up we know this this show this
this series is going to build up to the
um dance of dragons which was like a
targaryen civil war so we're going to
get some dragon on dragon warfare
in this series okay and not just a nice
dragon a weird zombie dragon fighting
regular dragon i'm talking you know
targaryens on the backs of dragons
eventually killing each other and
there's tons of mischief and people
marrying and killing we can expect every
dragon to die right
when you think about it because that's
the sad part because game of thrones
really is the show that embodies the
game f mary kill
sometimes all with the same person yeah
yeah why that's true yeah
and often that person is a relative yeah
that's true a blood pressure it's a
blood relative and i think there's a lot
of that in this uh this one he's married
to his niece yes yeah tyrion lannister
after married killed his shay
right oh that's true
justice for shea effects in the chat
[Laughter]
um but yeah i i don't know how much more
uh detail we want to get into eric will
have a great breakdown on the channel
for this trailer right we're going to be
comes out the show comes out in august
and we're going to be covering the hell
of it oh you better hell out of it both
on the channel new rock stars and on our
show here at the break room we'll be
talking about it every week we're jazzed
for it this summer right we get um
we get this show in august and then i
think just a couple weeks later we get
the lord of the rings amazon show yeah
so if you like swords and magic and
dragons and stuff like that this is the
late summer early fall for you you
better be excited about the dog days of
summer and the free-falling days of the
fall my friend my friend florence once
told me the dog days are over yeah okay
so
run back to your mother's
sunday is mother's day when did florence
pugh say that
daschle knows these these references do
not work
oh yeah daschle did let us know that
we've been getting the security guard's
name wrong the entire show yes it's jb
jb like the whiskey brand not jd you
like the bourbon brand yeah yeah
just made it more confusing yes uh oh we
got some other uh questions uh
that we can go through oh we've got kyle
howard thank you kyle for saying without
you guys i'd be uncultured and 25 richer
keep it up you guys thank you for the 25
oh yes and i guess you're welcome for
the culture my man it's our hey
it's our pleasure
oh pinkie's up thank you
there's nothing in that cup pinkies up
in my cup i like that frayed girl said
i'm rooting for the dragons not the
people that is exactly the same boat as
me the same or how i feel with uh we're
getting into something else
this is something interesting uh
santiago rodriguez
i'm terrible with the names uh so taking
into account that house of dragons like
200 years before civilization like seems
pretty much the same tech level like
same weapons and tools yeah all that
kind of stuff which that kind of mirrors
like true history i mean think about in
school right yeah when you were learning
about the renaissance that was 400 years
that that
took place during
in your mind it all gets like collapsed
into one tiny five years the industrial
revolution in like our real life society
like really pushed up you know
technology grows at an exponential rate
so it takes a long time for it to get
going so unless someone uh in westeros
is building a difference engine to make
the first computer it's going to take a
long time for them to get nowadays i got
to buy a new iphone every year this has
been a tommy tantrum
troy troy odyssey uh i don't think we
want to read it
[Laughter]
i'd rather be beat today it also makes
sense that like technology is not oh
sorry
brandon's still on well because like
sorry they're sending some of their
brightest minds to the wall yeah to to
not procrastinate
they're also sending rapists and thieves
and but some of their brightest minds
wind up on the wall too because because
they question things right they're
they're questioning uh the way things
work but and then the librarians they
all go to a tower and they don't get out
of the tower and they don't they don't
reproduce yeah and then the the kingdoms
aren't talking to each other not sharing
oh sharing so it's all a metaphor they
would be more advanced good point um
really quick before you get to yours uh
a lot of people on the chat we will get
to it soon uh they're saying check your
twitter tommy oh my god how long do i
have to leave that tweet up i think
until like just 24 hours
just four hours 24 hours i have to
delete my tweet
i wanted to point out dylan callahan
asking thank you for the super chat how
do i get one of those awesome mugs so
this is actually a funny story these
mugs were made a few years ago
background in the old school rogue
theory set big question set for fans
from the uh pre-pandemic era remember
those sets we got these mugs made the
company that makes these mugs no longer
exists
and it's almost impossible to find these
mugs so you can get different mugs on
the epic hero shop but uh literally the
10 of these that we have are the only
ones left in the world so sorry uh and
now that they know our location they're
going to come find us
burbank
also high tactical rhino i have my
glasses on today so i'm not you guys i
can read these screens i can read what
they say i say hi to some other people
well joel ralston he asked hey guys what
do we know about the werewolf by mcu
halloween special so far that's even a
contradiction because we we we're all
calling it a halloween special yes it is
a halloween i know it is but it's not
and they haven't really talked about it
they haven't given it a release schedule
i mean that's coming up not too long we
know so much more about the christmas
special than we know about that do you
think it's gonna lean scary or lean
i hope so i hope it's scary and not
jokey what is scary for disney plus i
it kind of guess scare me and i i mean i
think scary would be
seeing the transformation uh an american
werewolf from paris style oh
gross like body horror right well would
they be scary not scary is like man
walks behind trees
and goes back moon comes out man walk
out yeah well
you know it could still be pretty grisly
there could be murders and stuff like
that probably off camera will be implied
right you'll only kind of see it in the
edges of the frame things like that i
think they could that's a fun challenge
to make a really good pg-13
drowned a kid yeah that's scary hey papa
duke was scary as hell i'm pretty sure
that was pg-13
you know what else was scary
little monsters and i think that was
he peed in the apple juice that's true
that's disgusting
speaking of juice we've got a super chat
from our friend film juice
is they only want me for my film juice
is it worse we can't we're getting some
interesting questions today is it worse
to be disemboweled alive or frozen in
glass and unable to kiss oscar isaac
when he's right there
hey break room viewers
are you guys okay
it's because you asked for feet picks
they think i didn't miss
you
we didn't open the door we didn't open
the door you know what my twitter i
don't think
i don't think i'd like to be
disemboweled i think that sounds
terrible oh brave wow
folks i think i'd rather be frozen in
glass and unable to kiss us
it's frozen in glass mean like you get
hot glass
on you carbohydrates imagine it yeah
how do you get inside the glass the hot
glasses poured on you and then cooled
down
juice could you send us another
supercharger or like two filters you had
an infographic for this two giant two
giant pieces of glass you get pushed
together like science oh
i put a lot of plankton in between that
glass and watched
watched it like robert says hey guys
what do you guys think the chances of
john krasinski taking over the directing
chair for fantastic four uh i don't know
did he did he direct um both quiet
places he didn't do it directly
oh no he didn't direct you he doesn't
have to direct everything though right
guys i mean he could just you know play
he just directs two things marvel has
never allowed somebody to star and
direct oh oh
no that doesn't mean they never would
but
they have not i still want him to be my
um
reed richards yeah my readers mr
fantastic this is how i this is what if
i was him this is all i do and i mean
then you're going emily blunt sue storm
i do i'm such a weird like weirdo is
that a weirdo thing yeah
that's a weirdo i just like them i think
they're funny and quirky
they're jerks in real
life well i don't know about him but i
don't know english people tend to be a
delight i don't know she's really nice
funny and nice too um i'm sorry i'm
sorry krasinski blunt family i'm sure
you're wonderful people bad guys the
film juice too most of them are watching
actually film juice is a known uh nom de
plume of john krasinski
yeah yeah and that guy shows up in
everybody's chat asking about getting
disemboweled
but we assume it's a guy
that's true film juice i don't mean to
gender you apologies uh thank you all
for joining us i think this is going to
conclude uh the break room for today
uh the fourth in our epic launch week in
our one thousand part
franchise yeah this is going to go a
thousand episodes that's right day four
of one thousand we promise it uh we all
actually we have to rap because uh we're
all going to see multiverse of madness
yeah after this show um three of us are
going together jessica some of us are
seeing it in imax oh speaking of imax
let me hold the poster since
watch is watch him i'm the best friend
yeah if you've been watching all week
you noticed that was new in the
background because this set is ever
changing wow the imax folks sent us a
really nice poster yeah
if you if you've been watching the
channel you saw eric broke this poster
down
uh and then we're gonna break it down
and now we're gonna
thank you uh hi max folks uh yeah and
actually i think the rest of us though
we're seeing it in standard definition
this tonight we're going to see it in
imax later later this weekend uh and we
are going to be talking multiverse
madness today
we're going to be okay tommy
tommy's tommy's checking out feed pick
right now
we're going to be doing a spoiler-free
yeah tomorrow will be a spoiler-free
chat here on the show we don't if you're
showing up in the chat sport trying to
spoil stuff don't we're not interested
no spoilers we're gonna sell goofy pics
that's right yeah now monday's episode
will be spoiler filled okay that's when
we'll all gloves are off on monday uh
but tomorrow we will be talking about
multiverse madness but in a very uh cool
way to not ruin it
if you've got to spoil something
tomorrow spoiler
real quick real quick just a quick yes
or no do you guys bring notebooks into
the movies
these movies because i always go and
take notes and everyone looks at me
weird i have started doing it since i
worked in new rockets yeah
yeah
i always keep it all up here okay and
then i bug eric i'm like what happened
i'll go to the internet and go synopsis
yes and iris will have seen it six times
by the time we see it that is actually
true he's watching up on us he watched
it for the second time today uh you guys
are gonna love his breakdown coming out
well the ending explain comes out
tomorrow on the channel the breakdown
comes out saturday uh keep an eye out
for those god bless and and join us next
week we've got big plans next week
including our first friday the 13th
celebration is everybody going to make
it out alive
not some of us
i'll be right back oh god the virgins
usually live so i guess i'm safe
uh thank you all for joining us today
and for the last couple days we
appreciate you thanks for all the folks
in the chat thank you for the super
chats and the folks dropping a couple
bucks in the tip jar uh we love you
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you